bonsoir et bienvenue sur des gonades
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
ce soir notre invité jacques albi liane
n'est pas là mais il reviendra une
prochaine fois
puisque il y aller direct de linares en
ce moment même et donc il est obligé
pour son travail de continuer à les
suivre sur le site d'europe échec donc
c'est en ce moment
vendredi soir 21h nous avons donc un
remplaçant de choc voire même de luxe
il s'agit de nicolas la vallée bonsoir
nicolas bay côté je te remercie et loi
je sais pas si je remplacerais jacques
avec avantage
merci pour le compliment actualité du
moment c'est bien entendu le tournoi de
linares super tournoi qui vient de
commencer
kasparov karpov déjà une belle affiche
shirov l'écopôle garg riccio que des
très fort joueur donc aujourd'hui des
parties ont commencé avec un appareil
mans plutôt intéressant notamment la
partie karpov shirov qui a été
complètement époustouflante tout à fait
je pense que là on a eu droit à du grand
spectacle et je crois que le spectacle
continue encore les parties n'étant pas
toutes terminées effectivement donc des
appariements tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant puisque bon comment dire le
le challenger alexander gris tchouk
rencontre est donc judit polgar est donc
un match assez beaucoup de promesses le
match deux shows pôle gare à noter que
c'est peut-être le match pour la
dernière place
sachant qu est quand même que des stars
alors même si c'est deux très bons
joueurs c'est qu'on peut quand même
rappeler la performance d'alexandre gris
chaud que lors du championnat du monde
d'affilée il a quand même fait une
performance hallucinante
demi finaliste éliminé contre shirov
justement qui va retrouver ici dans un
match explosif avec beaucoup de
victoires beaucoup de matches nuls donc
alexander de choc effectivement qui est
capable de bien des surprises
laurent frayssinet l'avait annoncé dans
son pronostic de la semaine dernière
nicolas oui effectivement alexandre
grichka tout à montrer il doit faire ses
preuves et il a les nerfs solides et il
a les nerfs hyper hyper solide donc je
dirais simplement qu'il manque un peu
d'expérience à ce très très faim ce
niveau là c'est quand même le top top
top qui est aujourd'hui présent dans
câline ares le graton le gratin la crème
de la crème dans quel s quelques
licences des regrets tout pardon va va
tenir le coup va tenir le choc
c'est pas évident effectivement c'est
son premier tournoi en tout cas
apparemment première partie alexander de
chou blanc contre judit polgar avec les
noirs s'adonner avantage pôle gare quand
même toute la partie puisque great thou
que s'est fait complètement dominés et
finalement par une petite combinaison de
dernière minute il a réussi à tirer la
nulle part un échec perpétuelle donc
débuts difficiles pour great flu
peut-être mais des nerfs hyper solide
nerfs d'acier judit polgar à craquer la
première alors maintenant on arrive aux
cadors kasparov appareiller dans la
première ronde donc pour une partie pas
facile les noirs contre peter légaux
d'autant plus que peter l'écossé
quelqu'un qui est vraiment hyper hyper
solide pour gagner contre peter l'écho
sachant qu'il allait blanc il faut
vraiment s'accrocher mais bon c'est
quand même garry kasparov c'est comme
vérité sport mais d'un autre côté il
irrité sport à fait satisfait par la
nulle dans cette partie a priori il va
pas chercher plus loin que ça et
pourtant il a obtenu une très très belle
position
[ __ ] l'écho jouant la grande variante
de la nage d'orves arme principale garry
kasparov sortant une fois plus une
préparation canon dont il est coutumier
du fait et donc peter déco qui se
retrouvent à souffrir vie c'est ensuite
retournement de situation suite à une
cagade de kasparov
les copeaux un pion l'échec et activités
réciprocité des avantages et
inconvénients et finalement la partie va
probablement se terminer par là nul
n'est pas encore finie alors je crois
que laurent on nous avait dit à propos
de l'écho qu'il terminerait à quelque
chose comme plus sains ils le voyaient
plutôt en milieu de classement quand
même effectivement pu taire les coups +1
en fait il voulait bien dire ce qu'ils
voulaient dire là c'est que l'écho était
extrêmement bien préparées extrêmement
solide et extrêmement techniques et qu'
il est pas flambé mais d'un autre côté
il perd très peu donc plus sain plus de
picardie qu'on va gagner des parties
mais il va probablement perdre très près
ce qu'on peut dire que le style de peter
l'écho rejoint un petit peu celui de
krainik c'est à dire un jeu hyper solide
quand ils allaient blanc il est
imprenable
et quand ils allaient noire où on sait
il joue pour la nuit là alors on
comparait que plutôt l'écho bobby
fischer bon ce qui est plus flatteur
pour lui effectivement krainik c'est un
joueur solide mais positionnelle l'écho
je dirais plutôt un joueur solide mais
un peu tactique
pas tout à fait pareil york d'accord et
donc on en vient bien troisième match
donc un appariement extraordinaire
puisque c'est anatoli karpov qui jouent
contre contre contre alexis shirov donc
le on va dire le fougueux alexis shirov
contre le vieux tigre
karpov c'est une partie qui s'annonce
extraordinaire qu'un disons plutôt le
vieux chat puisque anatoli karpov et
quand même un peu pantouflard et vit sur
ses acquis échiquéen qui sont évidemment
énorme sachant qu'il a été champion du
monde pendant dix ans il se retrouve
contraint alexei shirov pont qui est
évidemment très fort fire on the board
toujours très actif très dynamique donc
une partie qui s'annonce explosive
d'autant plus que alexei shirov à
l'eiblen dans cette partie donc tout
était là pour que ça que ça explose
je crois que laurent était très très
dure envers anatolie il semble que
dans ses commentaires de lorsqu'il est
passé dernière émission
il avait dit de carpeaux hissera dans
les derniers karpov le voyez le voyais
vraiment pas il a parlé de has been top
aurait passé son temps donc on rappelle
ses les pronostics de laurent frayssinet
que vous pouvez revoir dans l'émission
diagonale de la semaine dernière avec
donc ces tags et l'intervention est là
il y a les commentaires pronostic de
laurent frayssinet et il voyait
également donc shirov second il voyait
second oui tout à fait yvette shirov
second mais d'un autre côté shirov on
sait qu'il a tendance à craquer oui mais
si on peut le dire commencer et mal
finir oui mais en général shirov craque
sur des tournois où il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de joueurs dix joueurs aux deux
joueurs c'est un médaillon n'a que six
joueurs
d'habitude il fait une première moitié
de tournoi extraordinaire puis
effectivement il craque à la fin mais là
il n'y a pas beaucoup de joueurs donc
peut-être qu'il va craquer dès le début
puisque la partie pour parer polikarpov
est pas encore fini mais pour l'instant
alexei shirov à une pièce de moins bons
alors évidemment il ya des compensations
puisque une pièce de moins à ce niveau
là ça ne se joue plus en tout cas donc
rappelle linares six joueurs un seul
vainqueur tout le monde rencontre tout
le monde deux fois ce qui fait donc dix
partis pour chacun donc très très gros
tournoi et on va nicolas maintenant je
crois passer à la partie commenté et
puis la partie inachevée
voyons ce chef-d'oeuvre partie shirov
alexei avec les blancs contre anatoli
karpov
nous allons envoyer l'échiquier et voilà
c'est un bon début et voilà c'est bien
nous avons donc tous alexei shirov les
blancs anatoli karpov les noir e 4 ça
commence comme d'habitude à mon avis ça
ne peut être qu'une carreaux calmes avec
anatoli karpov shirov qui a l'habitude
de jouer très actifs contre la carro
cannes c'est ça vient la voilà la
fameuse karo kann à noter que anatoli
karpov a quand même joué e 4 e 5 très
très longtemps puisque on se rappelle de
ses matches marathon contre garry
kasparov ou c'étaient des espagnols la
torture espagnol qui n'en finissait pas
que récemment et s'est mis à jouer là
tranquille et paisible
défense karo kann avec laquelle il a un
score faramineux il ne perd pratiquement
jamais il a son il a sa technique contre
garry kasparov il va peut-être nous
sortir 4 5 et sur l'espagnol ou faire la
variante berlinoise ce serait possible
c'est ça ne s'est fait facilement créer
quand même pas de piquant je le trouve
peut-être que anatoli karpov s'est
entraîné avec vladimir kramnik
d'ailleurs tout ça pour battre kasparov
puisque l'objectif étant fan de battre
kasparov en s'étant clairement des 4
alors là bon la défense karo kann pour
en savoir plus vous pouvez aller dans
diagonale la leçon nous avons une
analyse spéciale de cette défense qui a
été fait
oui qui est qui recommande donc une
ouverture simple qu'on va vous montrer
ici sur des cinq un moyen de lutter
contre la carro kahn avec qui on prend
des 5
donc vous avez dans le thème ouverture
joué 24 avec les blancs un schéma simple
pour lutter contre la carro cannes quand
vous voulez jouer tranquillement avec le
plan fouet en d3 c'est sa foi en d3 et
attaques sur le roi donc c'est un jeu
d'attaqué très systématique ya beaucoup
de systèmes pas beaucoup de variantes
c'est assez intéressant shirov lui est
plutôt coutumier d'une autre variante
puisque d'habitude il joue la grande
avance c'est qui consiste à avancer le
pion ici variante très complexe et ici
il n'a pas il n'a pas joué
bon on ne sait pas pourquoi avec le
cavalier qui vient en c3 une grosse
attaque sur la loi et c'est vrai que
c'est assez c'est assez tendue en fait
les noirs sacrifie du matériel mais pour
une très grande activité c'est c'est
souvent des parties et c'est en duo
endiablé et tout à fait dans le style de
chira flory et également de karpov
puisque c'est un des meilleurs
défenseurs du monde à l'heure actuelle
évidemment donc ça aurait donné quelque
chose de très combatif mais ici aussi
c'est pas mal cavalier ces trois pions
prendre quatre cavaliers prend 1,4 hélas
la variante karpov
pourquoi pas joué par karpov c'est
intéressant cavaliers 17 ses savantes
fétiche il a joué dans le match contre
cannes ce qu'il a joué dans tous ces
championnats du monde pratiquement
toutes ces dernières parties c'est
uniquement cette variante cavaliers 17
il ya d'autres coups at-on cavalli m6
directement dans cette variante
cavaliers fils directement ça existe
mais après les changes qui avaient les
premiers vallier les noirs sont obligés
de reprendre avec un pion ce qui
détériore donc leur structure de pions
l'idée du coup de karpov donc validé
cette c'est de jouer cavalier m6 et en
cas de prise reprendre avec le cas
valide donc karpov ne fait pas de
faiblesses dans sa structure de pions
c'est pas son style
l'autre coup dans cette position nicolas
ses relevés çà c'est le coup fourré cinq
jours et évidemment par karpov aussi un
quart peu à peu près tout essayé toute
façon qui donne une position très solide
pour les noirs une sorte de karo kann
améliorée de ce candidat mignon je crois
clip dans cette variante les blancs
essayer de prendre de l'espace sur les
droits mais en contrepartie c'est 2
doivent échanger leurs fous de cases
blanches et donc à neil le mauvais fond
blanc théorique de wimille et il est
théorique puisque le fou le foot cases
blanches des noirs est jamais vraiment
mauvais puisqu'il est sorti
il est donc derrière la structure de
pions mais dont kiev 5 c'est un coup car
il ya six ans est un autre le coup de
karpov qui a vraiment été remis à jour
par anatoli karpov seca et 17 sur quoi
shirov relève le challenge c'est à dire
qu'en fait dans cette position si les
banques font rien et bah ça va se
neutralisent et très très vite puisque
après qu'edf si ce qui va venir le
prochain coup des noirs c'est nos coûts
du cavalier sur la case f6 si on échange
les noirs reprennent du cavalier sortent
ensuite leur fou joue le pion aux sept
ans vaut 6 avec une position tout à fait
solide est égal j'ai presque envie de
dire si les noirs sortent leurs
cavaliers en 9,6 et que les blondes les
blancs prennent lecavalier après la
reprise nouvelle fois du cavalier en
fait les noirs auront sorti une pièce de
plus que les blancs et finalement ce
sont maintenant les blancs qui qui joue
le rôle des noirs aux usa on peut on
peut voir ça comme ça en tout cas
effectivement le cavalier bleu on va
jouer trois fois ce qui n'est pas une
bonne opération pour être échangé tout
de suite alors qu'avec g5 alexei shirov
déjà à lui dit non on échangera pas les
cavaliers et deuxième chose il lui tend
un petit piège assez connu enfin assez
curieux sur h6 par exemple oui alors
c'est sûr h 6 mais c'est très très très
très intéressant h6 donc c'est vraiment
le coup qui dit bon vas tu as mis ton
cavaliers là qu'est ce qu'il fait là
je comprends pas pourquoi et bien là il
ya le coût qui avait dit aussi ce
nicolas qui est très très sûr vignes
avec une menace de maths par la dame en
h5
c'est à dire que oui en fait il n'y a
pas de bonus mais si les noirs
s'aventure à prendre le cavalier boom
échec alors j'ai six forcée d'un projet
si matt
donc ça c'est un match assez connu assez
joli et si en fait les noirs ne prennent
pas qu'est ce qui se passe et lancy les
noirs ne prennent pas c'est le truc
critiques après qu'elle eut six ont peu
bougé la dame par exemple en b 6
et là on prend le fou tout simplement
avec un léger avantage pour les blancs
puisque on appris de la paire de fou en
toute simplicité et puis les
la lino avons un problème de
développement les blancs gagne la peur
de faut effectivement salaire salaire à
sa nature la position n'est pas si si
simple à gagner il faut encore la
technique mais en tout cas kg 5e
s'attend un petit piège sur la justice
donc ce petit coup qui va lui aussi tout
à fait sympa ou un hôtelier karpov
évidemment connaît qu'on lui fait pas
cavalier f6 solide food et 3 donc là
toujours pareil issifou des trois paraît
étrange
en fait pourquoi pas fou ans et quatre
mises en justement en mettant l'accent
sur la faiblesse en 9 sets ça serait
possible effectivement nicolas dans
cette question de développer de fou sur
la case c4 mais de toute façon les noirs
vont jouer un set au 6 mai s'est enfermé
le fou de deux cases blanches des noirs
mais ils n'auront pas le choix ils vont
être obligés de le jouer les noirs ces
terres convoitées après fou des 3t le
coût de la partie les noirs doivent
jouer aussi ils n'ont pas d'autres coûts
dans cette position et à ce moment là on
s'aperçoit que le fou c4 est moins bien
placés en d3 parce que justement il y un
mur en 6 cécile fous étaient ici il y
aurait les documents la petite remarque
au passage sur la justice
il y a encore là même qui avait lui
aussi ce toujours cette fois ci c'est le
fou cette fois ci et comme la dame ne
peut plus venir au match 5 c'est le fou
qui vient manger si ça c'est non l'échec
et mat
mais je crois que cas nathalie
connaissait celui là aussi voilà un
hôtel il les connaît tous donc ici le 6
très logique cavaliers un enlève 3 et
maintenant ça y est suracheté
de toute façon on va revenir problème
sur la case aux 4 si je dis pas de
bêtises et puis j'ai pas tout à fait ce
que ça a changé mais ça change des
choses fou des six dames 2 pourquoi pas
et donc on ne pouvait pas
à jouer h61 coup avant c'était pas
possible aux essais c'est une question
tout à fait intéressante h61 coup avant
tout à fait possible je ne sais pas
exactement ce qui se passe en conviant
aux 4 quand même mais j'ai du mal
j'ai du mal à me rappeler des barouds
précise faut dire que la partie vient
d'être joué on n'a pas trop eu le temps
de réviser nos ouvertures d'autant plus
que celle là est ce qu'on peut envisager
dans ce type de position un éventuel
sacrifice en os 6 on peut l'envisager
mais je pense pas très longtemps c'est
pas non je pense je pense que c'est pas
un bon sacrifice nicolas parce qu'on ne
prend on donne une pièce quand même pour
justin pions et on n'a pas sorti tant
pièce que ça la position des noirs est
très solide très compacte scandait
effectivement une pièce pour un pion
mais bon après on derocles aura le roy
on peut mentionner vite fait la variante
ce qu'elle valait préemption prend fou
j'ai six échecs pour des rockets droit
leroy montano set et là il n'y a plus
rien difficile de trouver des
justifications à la pièce sacrifier donc
tout simplement un petit conseil à nos
internautes ne sacrifiez pas quand vous
n'avez pas quelque chose soit quelque
chose de très concret c'est-à-dire une
vente forcée soit le sentiment qu'il va
y avoir une initiative énorme parce que
vous avez sorti beaucoup plus de pièces
parce que vous avez tout une énorme
attaque sur le roi quand y'a rien de ça
il faut pas il faut pas donner food et 6
donc h si c'était possible
dames 2 h 6 maintenant le cavadee
revient au centre
tout ça c'est logique qu'elle prend
cavaliers on prend de la dame
donc effectivement les blancs on a
l'impression qu'ils ont amélioré
puisqu'ils ont réussi à prendre de la
dame henri iv pourtant là on les noirs
peuvent continuer leur leur déploiement
par cavalli et six attaquants la dame
est et replaçant le cavalier
favorablement
alors qu'à venir ici c'est un coût qui
n'est pas forcément recommandé dans
cette position pour plusieurs raisons
qui est quand même un cologie pourtant
c'est un coup assez logique mais alors
la dame blanche reviendrait sur la case
2 tout simplement
et ensuite on s'aperçoit que le
cavaliere 3 va venir en cinq avec une
très très belle case qui n'est plus
contrôlée par le cahier dès cette es1
cavagnan lot 5 c'est très ennuyeux
puisque il ya des perspectives des
attaques sur le roi sur le futur roi
avec le fouet le cavalier donc anatoli
karpov préfère ne pas laisser le câble
et blanc revenir sur les cadeaux c'est
ce qu'on appellerait un avant-poste un
avant-poste exactement un cavalier
avancé
dans le camp ennemi d'un premier 4 c'est
cette c5 ça c'est la réaction centrale
typiquement tous assez théorique
évidemment donc les joueurs connaissent
très bien
d'alger 4 alors là il ya eu plusieurs
tentatives beaucoup de fous qui ont été
essayées et je crois que la dernière
blague entre guillemets d'anatolie
karpov c'était de jouer le coup droit et
fuite wal al shehri curieux mais anatoli
karpov est coutumier du fait dans ce
genre de position il va complètement
contre les principes les grands
principes de l'ouverture en europe
pratiquement jamais le rock pas il l'est
sans roi au centre avec aider si les
blancs font le petit rock
pourquoi pas aussi déclencher une
attaque sur les droits puisqu'il la tour
est restée sur la colonne h
éventuellement eux-mêmes déclencher une
attaque en attendant le plan des noirs
est très simple ils vont prendre en d4
mais quelque part c'est fille la
structure c'est vrai que on peut
comprendre ce plan de royal fleet
puisque c'est difficile quand même pour
les noirs de roque est dans cette
position on a les pièces blanches qui
vont vite monté il ya une faiblesse en
âge 6 avec un sacrifice éventuelle du
fou qui est en c1 bien avec la
préparation adéquate
mais c'est vrai que la dame ayant une
position telle que l'on peut le voir sur
cet échiquier avec angers 4 toutes les
pièces blanches convergent vers le petit
rock donc c'est difficile de roke est le
grand roque étaient quasiment aussi
impossible vu que le voyez plus et psion
devant devant le roi
côté grand jeu voilà en fait le jeu est
en train de s'ouvrir côté elle dame
donc on imagine mal aussi un grand rôle
de ce côté là d'autant plus que là ya
pas mal de temps de retard donc roi fx
est quand même un coup j crew
intéressant mais là bon il ya le coup
quand même qui est plus connu plus
respecter c'est le coude à 9,6 ce qui
évite de se dire ok donc on donne pas
tout de suite notre adresse on met la
dame sur une bonne case ont des
champions g7 ce qui était la menace
directe et le plan des blancs maintenant
c'est tranquille b6 fou 17
on sort nos pièces et le roy on verra
plus tard et la dame c'est une position
sécurisé ici louis dame noire puisque on
voit que le fou ne peut pas venir
l'attaqué g5 étant contrôlé par le pion
à 6 donc ici à priori la position des
noirs ressemble à une position solide
donc pour l'instant rien de particulier
ces trois on tient le centre mais c'est
une idée c'est en fait c'est plus subtil
que ça puisque après psion prend des cas
l'idée est de reprendre avec le pion
avec le pion et non pas avec le cavalier
ça paraît ça paraît étrange quand même
comme décision sa part étrange mais d'un
autre côté si on envisage la reprise
avec lecavalier
on voit qu'on atteint cette fameuse
structure avec trois contre deux à
gauche pour les blancs là je parle en
termes de pions en trois pions contrat
d'option pour les blancs et quatre pions
contre trois pions pour les noirs à
droite de l'échiquier
ça c'est une structure qui est
légèrement avantageuse pour les noirs si
les blancs n'arrive pas à voir une
attaque directe en milieu de jeu en
milieu de la majorité centrale puisqu'on
parle de ça est avantageuse pour le camp
attaquants oui puisque il ya quatre
pions devant le roi contre 3 points
devant le roi salir idiot de dire ça
mais pas du tout puisque capillon ça
protège n'octroie tout simplement donc
là une chance d' attaques des noirs sont
supérieures dans cette position oui
parce qu'en fait les pions de la
majorité centrale vont pouvoir prendre
les cases du centre et ses générateurs
d'attac noble idéal ça c'est un 'sell
phenom s'il ya beaucoup de questions
quand c'est réussi on peut avancer
d'options quand on en a quatre
quand on a trop on peut passer trop trop
affaiblissant puis on prend des quatre
donc excellent shirov reproduction il
crée lui-même actions isolées
il ya son idée alexei shirov mais c'est
très très douteux de jouer puis on prend
des quatre puisque anatoli karpov lie
très très content il joue b6 il est
complètement dans son élément il a une
belle structure de pions il joue donc
contre un pion isolé c'est vraiment le
pur anatoli karpov et l excès chirac lui
va chercher le dynamisme c'est le vieux
chat qui va essayer de
le félin c'est exactement ça il va il va
jouer tranquillement il va tourner ses
pièces pendant des heures ça va être
très dur moralement pour shirov
méconnaissant alexei shirov nous sommes
qu'au 13e coup c'est forcément une
préparation maison bien entendu pour
l'instant les deux joueurs connaissent
encore très bien cette position
ça joue donc petit rock fou mais cette
fois 3 c'est vrai que le fouquet temps
bessette convergent vers la case f3 avec
la dame aurait six ans en comme une
faiblesse il ya la possibilité de
prendre f3 tout de suite ce qui va
provoquer un affaiblissement de la
structure d'options des blancs
dramatique puisqu'on aura trois îlots de
pions contre deux pour côté noir avec un
entre deux et quatre contre quatre îlots
du pion oui et en plus des pions doublé
sur la colonne fcc la partie nicolas
c'est la partie alexei shirov avait ses
idées
anatoly karpov aussi donc là il ya un
débat qui va s'instaurer alors on va
montrer tout de suite
anatoly karpov commence par le coup h 6
h 5 chasse la dame blanche qui doit
venir sur les 15 h 30 prendre l'espace
est maintenant il prend un f3 donc là
deux solutions soit reprendre la dame
soit rendue pions si on prend de la dame
on arrivait en finale directement oui et
ça devient catastrophique quand même
pour les pour les noms pour les blancs
oui tout à fait il reprendre de la dap
c'est une très mauvaise option
d'ailleurs alex et chirac ne s'y est pas
trompé puisque après d'un programme
puis on prend le cavalier noir vient
directement sur la case et 6 août ours
et 8 d'abord c'est pas mal enfin il ya
deux possibilités soit on fait qu'il y
avait six pour venir tenir la caisse des
cinq très vite brutalement oui parce que
lecavalier ne peut pas être chassés de
cette cave lequel ne peut pas de chasser
le fou e3d blanc n'a aucune place sur
l'échiquier où il sera bien placé c'est
donc un net avantage noir avec aucune
chance d' attaque pour chiens donc dans
ce type de position la perte de fouilles
ne compense nullement la faiblesse truc
la faiblesse structurelle des pions non
on peut pas vraiment parler de paire de
faux ici effectivement il y en a deux
mais il y en a un qui ne joue pas et
qu'il jouera jamais c'est le fou ici
pointé en verre qui est vraiment mauvais
pour tout le reste de la partie donc
c'est une demie père de fou le faux de
cazaux nardin qui donc ne vaut pas grand
chose après vous présentera les tj
reprend dû plonger ça al'air sa position
à l'air
affreux on ne le cachera pas la position
avec ses chiens enfin pas l'air terrible
mais nous sommes qu'au 17e coup là je
sais quand même étrange de commandes
explique tant que qu'alexi chauffer puis
arrivée dans une telle ou telle position
telle variante telle variante et bien je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas ce que je
sais c'est que les c'est pas si simple
la position actuelle n'est pas si simple
pourquoi parce que justement avec shirov
un fou de cases blanches alors qu à
noter lecteur profane en a plus il vient
de le donner donc ce fou peut venir soit
sur la case aux quatre soit
éventuellement sur la case à 6 pour
empêcher une tournoi redevenir ans évite
donc prendre la colonne s'est il ya
beaucoup de perspectives il peut venir
aussi sur la case b5 soit une de ces
trois cases la fête se fout vraiment
c'est l'atout d'alexei shirov dans cette
position est ce que c'est pas une
stratégie délibérée du grand maître
espagnol pour emmener karpov justement
dans des situations dans des positions
un peu atypique où justement bien la
folie est possible sur l'eau sur
l'échiquier
difficile de dire qu'on entraîne karpov
dans les positions atypique qui connaît
pas très bien puisque quand même dix ans
champion du monde 40 ans d'expérience il
connaît toutes les positions 30 ans
d'expérience sur la carreau cannes dont
trente ans sans la terre locale il est
vraiment vu il y en a vu passer des
positions et ici bon bah de toute façon
il n'y a pas besoin de la connaître
dans la mesure où il a ce qu'il veut
c'est à dire pas de faiblesses d'options
une position il peut tourner les pièces
est allé ramasser simplement les
faiblesses de l'autre donc la nature et
karpov 61 alexei shirov aussi puisque
lui il peut bouger s'en fout il peut
avoir une activité aussi sur la colonne
c est il à son levier de pions d4 d5 on
voit que les noirs contrôle pas bien
cette case encore donc il ya du
dynamisme pour alexei shirov contre du
du jeu sur le long terme pour anatoli
karpov donc c'est vraiment la
confrontation des styles c'est le débat
d'idées on en parle beaucoup en ce
moment en politique avec la mairie de
paris met donc là il ya un vrai débat
d'idées exceptionnellement essai sur
diagonale la partie shiro ferrebeuf
petite parenthèse tourner vite ça y est
car peuvent place bien ces pièces il a
écouté il commence à tourner avec
polikarpov torah c'est un pur shirov
logique prend la colonne c'est chacun en
fait tu prends la colonne qui lui semble
logique
oui oui tout les noirs envie de croquer
le pion en des cas tout au moins de
faire une pression sur ce pion les
blancs envie d'attaquer donc oui je
comprends tout à fait si cool un g5
alors ça y est anatoly karpov chauffe il
il s'énerve il veut attaquer le roi de
shirov est en fait il y eut il essaie
d'attaquer des deux côtés de l'échiquier
finalement oui principalement du côté
droit principalement du côté droit mais
néanmoins il jette un petit nez un petit
oeil quand même sur la faiblesse du pion
qui tendait 4 effectivement alors il a
une idée ce coup j'ai 5
enfin il a deux idées la première c'est
de jouer au g4 dans certaines variantes
ça va marcher
ça c'est une idée la deuxième c'est
peut-être d'aller jouer au f4 pour
taquiner un peu la position des blancs
menaces et éventuellement fou prend fous
pourquoi pas échanger des pièces puisque
c'est toujours bon d'échangé des pièces
quand on a une meilleure structure
d'options ce qui est le cas ici pour
karpov
donc j'ai 5 un coût qui n'engage à rien
qui enferme la dame
des l'excelsior quand même on voit que
cette dame n'a plus beaucoup de caves
d'ailleurs elle en a jamais eu beaucoup
mais là c'est horrible en voyant cette
position on a c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que le jeu va s'ouvrir
d'une manière ou d'une autre que le pion
le pion qui tendent et quatre sur qui
montrait en rouge sur l'écran va se
lancer
en d5 pour affaiblir le roi
effectivement et peut-être quelqu'un
anatoli karpov et saïb a lui aussi de
son côté dedans brouiller un peu les
cartes et de et de jouer le tout pour le
tout c'est une partie sans compromis
visiblement il est en train de se
prémunir indirectement contre le coût
des cinq puisque quand on voit des
saints qui aura acquis 25 mai c'est la
partie tout ça ça a eu lieu dans la
partie et ensuite on voit que le purgé
cinq mois on sera vraiment devenir
handicapé ça on va vous l'expliquer tout
de suite fourcade joué par shirov donc
là c'est cache un bon coup de fouet il
défend le point f3 qui peut être
sensible il prépare à l'avancé des
quatre des cinq donc un bon coup
positionnelle rose est la spécialité
d'interpol
il ne manque pas et la caisse qui
prépare à l'atelier bien ils préparent
g5 g4 cash sachant que le plan ne sera
pas reprise puisqu'il y aura trop de
trop de contre je il a lié les deux
tours donc maintenant la toque et en
tout temps au hand et 8 peuvent
coulisser très rapidement sur cette
rangée pour venir et bien chatouiller le
roi qui est en face effectivement ça
commence à devenir très chaud pour
alexei shirov donc là on ne sait pas
trop comment il va s'en sortir
il finit par jouer tour f en e1 oui je
peux comprendre ce coup puisque c'est
tout à fait dans la logique de pousser
le pion en d5
alors là il ya un vis-à-vis
effectivement nicolas la tour qui se
mène sur directement dans la colonne qui
va sur le roi et demi donc l'idée c'est
bien entendu tout et des 4 des 5 1 pour
exploser un peu la position
la structure de pions au tour du roi
noir casser cette structure donc c'est
un coup d'attaquants fait ça c'est
amusant c'est vraiment une commune une
position particulière parce que on n'a
pas un côté le roi n'a pas rauque et de
l'autre côté le roi rauque et met dans
une situation un peu compromise et
finalement c'est le premier qui va
arriver on qui va gagner donc c'est un
peu comme si on était en rock opposé
mais ce n'est pas le cas effectivement
bon c'est pas une sorte de reproposer
puisque les noirs ont choisi l'europe
centrale on va dire c'est à dire mettre
le roi au centre et ne pas l'amener sur
les côtés alors que les noirs sont les
blancs on sait le petit rock donc les
rois sont pas situés pareil donc chacun
cherche à attaquer le roi et demi c'est
le principe de base du jeu d'échecs il
faut aller mater le roi
c'est ce que font les deux adversaires
ici tu aurais fait un fouet f4 scellier
anatoli karpov qui a pris la case la
case qu'il aspirait ça c'est un coup
intéressant dans la mesure où il veut
jouer fou prend fou et dira shirov
l'asie maintenant tu choisis si tu
prends du pillon c'est en fait un petit
tour en sable ocre à ta propre retour et
si tu prends de la tour et ben ça
explosera de la structure de pions et
jouera plus qu'à prendre des cartes d
iran donc
donc ça c'est un petit coup malandain
anatoli karpov mais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'on a presque envie de reprendre
du puy ont quand même pour pour reformer
un peu la structure
depuis l'entente d'option sera
obligatoire mais d'un autre côté il n'a
pas forcément envie c'est affaiblissant
pour le roi bouger un pion fc jamais
être dans cette variante si ce sont les
blancs qui s'empresse de prendre le fou
de cases noires c'est la partie c'est la
part d'autres on va y venir
à noter dans cette position le coup j'ai
cinq g4 qui était quand même possible
qu' une variante qu'il faut mentionner
puisque c'est là-bas en direct d'attac
on voit tout de suite que si les blancs
près d'angers 4 enfin voit tout de suite
avec un peu d'entraînement après pu
reprocher car vous allez ça commence à
devenir difficile sur le pion il ya du
gh2 voilà le pion h2 va probablement
tombé puisqu'il sera attaqué et par la
tour et par le fou catastrophe en
catastrophe mais sur le coup j'ai 4 on
joue simplement d'alger 2 le seul coup
dans cette position et là on ne peut pas
mettre une tour g8 tout à fait du tout
ranger vite c'est possible mais là
simplement le roi qui s'en va on lâche
un très solide cette case achat et là on
voit pas comment anatoli karpov peut
continuer son attaque d'un match 4
damages quatre possibilités c'est un
coût qui est tentant oui mais là ça donc
ça force le coup f4 on ferme l'enferment
la position voilà tout à fait et au coup
d'après le coût des cinq est inévitable
tandis que ce sera aux blancs d'attaqué
après et on voit que l'attak noirs
commencent à manquer un peu de de
souffle oui tout à fait les noirs
épuisent leurs cartouches en fait et
maintenant et en plus c'est vrai que la
dame blanche qui est en g2 avec le fou
qui est en eux quatre formes une bonne
batterie aussi également non content les
pièces blanches son record données oui
c'est ça et le roi blanc est en totale
sécurité donc ici peut-être anatoli
karpov a bien fait de ne pas s'empresser
d'attaqué il joue avec kat d'abord un
petit coup subtil et assez mal on vous
prend fou dame prend hélas cette fois ci
on pouvait pas prendre du plomb alors
pour prendre du plomb c'est pas c'est
pas dans la logique de la position qu'a
tout à fait parce que quand on prend du
plomb on se ferme beaucoup de
possibilités et on voit pas comment on
va attaquer le roi plan une fois qu'il
se rend à agen
il n'y a aucune possibilité de
l'attaquer donc pour ce faire les
possibilités d'attaquer une fois plus
son épuisement cartouches puisque la
taxe se retrouvent essoufflé et sans
perspectives ça c'est pas une
bonne solution il faut toujours garder
des possibilités d'attaquer la y en a
plus donc c'est aux blancs de louer tout
simplement au plan d'eau au plan
d'attaqué c'est anatoli karpov ne
voulait pas donc il est rendre la dame
logique puisque maintenant il ya
toujours cette poussée g5 g4 dans l'air
un levier qui effectivement assez
dangereux des 5 gyres flux aussi à son à
son levier à son levier à dire donc la
ccc partie en fait ça y est la sajo de
la tension est à son maximum
ça devient extrêmement chaud extrêmement
chose les pièces volent dans tous les
sens et finalement shirov est arrivé une
fois de plus à son objectif puisque ça y
est il vient de mettre le feu sur
l'échiquier
oui mais d'accord mais anatoli karpov
aussi arriver à son objectif parce que
il a une position il a plus qu'à
défendre et s'il arrive à tout défendre
et bien finalement qu'est-ce qu'il va
parler c'est la structure depuis en
mauvaise alexei shirov donc on est en
plein dans le débat voilà j'ai de
l'attak avec une structure pourri si tu
arrives à part l attaque
tu vas gagner la partie maintenant c'est
pas sûr qu'ils arrivent donc là on est
en plein dedans
une partie typique super party avec un
développement avenir plein de promesses
alors nous nous connaissons trop shirov
dans ce type de partie pour avoir une
envie fracassante de sacrifier du
matériel shirov sacrifient toujours
quelque chose un pion au minimum souvent
une pièce cette fois de pièce est ce
qu'il va nous sacrifier une pièce dans
cette position et lois et ça vient ça
vient ça vient de toute façon il ya une
pièce dont il n'avait plus besoin donc
ils s'en débarrassent et c'est ce qu'on
va voir tout de suite alors là anatoly
karpov
c'est à vous de jouer il a vu une case
ses terres que au coude avant le pion
était en d4
maintenant il est parti en dessin qu'il
ya une case noire en hausse 1 qui se
libère tout à fait donc il y va anatolie
c'est pas mal la menace c'est g4
maintenant un cash suivies de prises en
f3 donc ça serait de la boucherie il ça
vient vite quand même il faut absolument
éviter ça tu comprends aussi ce alors on
va me dire ça n'évite pas la menace est
en fait si puisque maintenant sur g4 sur
aide à mach 4 échecs
donc si le pion avoir songé 4 ont fait
l'échec en h4 au match 4
et on pourrait pas prendre le pion c'est
vrai que c'est très
c'est très très très tendue on pouvait
pas prendre le pion au no 6 à ce moment
là s'il est alors la partie est bien
plus bien plus énorme puisque la anatoli
karpov joué le coup et sa tef 5 f5 et
d'allant donc là c'est là c'est une
maman
dans photo quoi c'est le moment faute
aux moments d'anthologie oui tout à fait
et donc les noirs ont un pion de plus en
un tournemain pour l'instant ils peuvent
reprendre un os 6 c'est une possibilité
ils peuvent jouer le g5 g4 c'est une
autre possibilité
anatoly karpov nous pond le coup f5 et
l'aller les blancs peuvent pas le
prendre ce pion en raid 5 et non il
n'est pas il est pas prenable
on va expliquer les raisons pourquoi
après la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est pourquoi anatoli karpov n'a pas
pris on veut 6 ça c'est une bonne
question je pense que la réponse est la
suivante il ya plus d'attaqué après il
n'y a plus de texte sur le petit robot
blanc
il ya beaucoup moins d' attaque ensuite
puisqu'on n'arrive pas trop à l'attaqué
ce qu'on rêve trois ans il ya d'alger 3
qui va être un bon coup de défense pour
et blanc le fou au caire très très très
fort donc les blancs vont par l attaque
des noirs puisqu'elle n'existe quasiment
plus est ce qu'on peut dire que
on s'acheminerait vers une finale où les
dames auraient disparu forcément et à ce
moment là là là les îlots de pions
blancs finalement seraient compensées
également parler les îlots depuis en
noir puisque c'est vrai qu'on a un pion
arriérés devant le roi noir
alors il faut pas tout à fait résonner
comme ça parce que les la structure de
pions blanche sera toujours plus
mauvaise dans la mesure où il ya des
pions doublé donc ça c'est un élément en
revanche le fou est supérieur aux
cavaliers c'est ça qui compense la
mauvaise structure de pions
le fou blanc en quatre centrales qui
rayonne partout parce qu'il ya des
bâtiments sur les deux ailes parce que
des pions sur les deux ailes ça c'est un
principe le fois plus fort que calais
quand il ya des pions partout parce
qu'il peut arriver plus rapidement sur
le d'un beau solo de gien bouteilles
d'eau de vichy qui l'a fait donc ici
anatoli karpov ne veut pas de cette
finale entre guillemets où il voit pas
trop les perspectives
en revanche il trouve un truc superbe le
coup f5 dont on sait plus qui met le feu
parce que ce coup d'où vient il a au
final alors explications on a presque
envie de dire que karpov regardant
shirov et jouant avec 5 mai alexis tu
vas pas me la faire à moi c'est
exactement ça l'om le sait quand même le
monde à l'envers ils inversent les rôles
un petit peu donc dame prend f5 n'a pas
été joué effectivement c'était pas très
bon ce coup puisque là je crois qu'il ya
simplement d'un programme ni quoi sans
trop se casser fu panda mais les
les blancs n'ont pas un plan de plus
dans cette partie il est bon il ya une
pointe tactique car la forme d'échec au
roi voilà
et en plus ces attaques la tour don
croisé deux cavaliers prend tout à
tourcoing cavaliers et c'est terminé
et finalement c'est les noirs qui ont
une qualité plus avec probablement une
transformation assez facile donc ici on
ne peut pas prendre le pion f5 à cause
de cette fourchette
cause de cette pointe voilà on peut
difficilement bouger le fou aussi
puisqu'il ya quand même g4 qui va
peut-être non pas g4 mais on peut bouger
le fou on aurait pu vous de foot 17
mais ce n'est pas un coup qu'on a
vraiment envie de jouer mais en voyant
cette cette folie sur l'échiquier les
joueurs ont dû dépenser beaucoup de
temps à ce moment là à ce moment de la
partie n ya aucun doute
anatoly karpov est en gros ein hod dans
cette position synon c'est-à-dire crise
de temps il a plus beaucoup de temps
faut donc qu'ils jouent vite qu'ils
trouvent très vite les coups et pourtant
il nous sort f5 et pourtant il nous sort
f5 mais là je pense que ça allait encore
alors après les tours c'est cet échec
die zeit shirov un échec dit
intermédiaire cirque en fait le fouetter
emprise au lieu de le défendre le bouger
on fait chaque haut rang sa force donc
les noirs à réagir ils peuvent pas
prendre le fou en même temps et là on
peut pas attaquer à la fois le fouet la
tour en jouant par exemple le roi en d6
c'est la partie c'est la partie c'est la
partie roi des six attaques
effectivement et la tour et le fou est
donc shirov la donne et sa pièce alors
finalement shirov d'un de sa pièce il
est obligé l'aï eu en fait il la donne
pas il la perd dans cette position c'est
à dire qu'après f5 la perte d'une pièce
c est vraiment forcer oui c'est fort
c'est être surtout bessette il y avait
d'autres problèmes qui étaient assez
gravissime avec sa chirouf sacrifie à
moitié c'est à dire qu'il est un peu
obligé de la donner donc en fait ils
perdent les pièces villa du jeu c'est il
a du jeu mais c'est quand même
d'habitude c'est lui qui la donnent
délibérément sylla il la donne
parce qu'on lui force la main c'est puis
tout à fait la même chose oui mais c'est
toujours difficile de voir la limite
parce que ça fait peut-être très
longtemps qu'il a vu cette variante
il a vu qu'il pouvait donner la pièce et
donc il n'a pas cherché autre chose
c'est possible aussi on peut pas
vraiment savoir ce qui se passe dans la
tête d'un joueur comme shirov c'est à
dire des joueurs de ce niveau là sont
capables de calculer vraiment très très
très très loin en profondeur c'est
énorme c'est assez considérable séquence
est considérable c'est vrai que c'est
d'un possible
il calcule une certaine profondeur tout
reprend 1,7 puis on prend fou je
saignais pièce de plus mes robes droites
karpov dans le vent un peu a l'air
complètement dans le vent le roi
d'ateliers karpov bombay alors est-ce
que le squelette effectivement le
les tours blanches sans pouvoir
inquiéter le roi a suffisamment parce
que d'expérience je sais que le couple
cavalier dames contre un roi ce ci aussi
chaud c'est que je prenne mon fort c'est
extrêmement fins l'oeil un problème pour
les blancs et nicolas c'est que la dame
n'arrive pas à entrer dans l'action ça
c'est l'un c'est un gros problème quand
même on n'arrive pas à faire jouer la
dame donc on peut faire un échec avec la
tour mais ça nous conduit complètement
nulle part puisque le roi vient par
exemple en c6 et larry latham n'arrive
pas à venir plus d'échecs
déjà c'est la mauvaise bande la dame
peut pas venir les voir menacés changer
les tours pièce de plus près c'est
terminé s'est perdu donc elle qui
cherche trouve la ressource eau 6 au 7
qui donne des cars pour la dame
c'est à dire notamment la case 17
éventuellement il redonne un pion et la
case aussi ce nom là le clan est
défendue par la tour nicolas donc pour
l'instant il donc patient la silla tout
revient à bouger maintenant on fait
notre échec en d1 avec la dame qui
jaillit en os 6 bref oui là ça devient
très très bien c'est difficile d'être
chaud aussi plus qui attaque qui ont peu
plus et retrouver cavaliers proprio f3
échec au roi intermédiaire donc donc là
en fait karpov ne perd pas son sang
froid et joue son va-tout également
karpov à mandali karpov mon île a
calculé le set qui est le seul coup dans
cette position le seul coup envisageable
qu'avec épreuve trois échecs
intermédiaire shirov l'a calculé aussi
là il ya le choix des cases bon on peut
aller en h1 on peut aller en f1
également ses deux cases d'une valeur à
peu près équivalente le pense et je
pense également que shirov n'a pas dû
prendre trop de temps dans cette
position pour réfléchir aux différentes
possibilités sachant que les deux coups
avait à peu près le même impact
non croit f1 il fallait en choisir un
seul et 2 et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
voit alors dallas on voit
complication terrible la menace a peut
être tourné un échec ça peut être bon tu
comprends tout évidemment donc ici
anatoli karpov un petit peu sait plus
trop quoi faire
il joue le coup de défense avec gros
sang froid alors énorme sang froid tour
des élites qui ont des revenus de 8 à la
dame blanche de venir sur la case 17
donc là il faut quand même un sang-froid
énorme j'ai presque envie de dire est
dans cette position ce qui va sauver les
noirs je ne sais pas s'ils sont encore
sauvé mais le fait que la tour blanche
qui sur la première rangée ne puisse pas
venir sur la colonne c c'est fondamental
dans cette position c'est un facteur
extrêmement important
c'est un facteur extrêmement important
serait décisif bon pourquoi et d'un
simplement parce que la dame noire
contrôle sept cas c'est un donc
effectivement c'est c'est très important
mais karpov mon il a le feeling pour ça
il sent bien quelles pièces peuvent
aller ou pourquoi saddam et bien un f4
c'est parce que ça empêche la tour
blanche sur la colonne c est ça il n'a
pas besoin de réfléchir en fait car pas
fini très très intuitif c'est il n'a pas
besoin de calculer il sens qui se basent
il sait que le roi noir a trouvé une
cage à l'abri malgré le fait que toutes
les pièces blanches maintenant viennent
à l'attak a noté kasparov a quand même
réussi à les déstabiliser
même si anatolie sentait qu'il allait
sauver son roi et cfm était quand même
ça arrive mais il a quand même une
intuition glorieuse à ce niveau là on
n'est pas champion du monde je pense
sans par hasard d'amener cet échec avec
ces chiffres évidemment la première
occasion possible de remplacer saddam il
y va leroy montant aux 5
définitivement bon c'est quand même une
case forcé sinon si on allait de l'autre
côté on allait se faire mater tressage
penser ça l'irrité
on voit pas on voit plus trop d'échecs
pour les blancs mis à part dams et 7
mais bon l ex ait choisi le coutour d1
et bien quelque part alexis shirov a
réussi à activer toutes ces pièces
maintenant les dames et les deux tours
participé à l'attaqué alors par contre
on a un cavalier une dame qui peuvent
faire très mal quand même que tu es noir
oui oui oui ça c'est effectivement ce
effectivement totalement vrai visage les
cavaliers ça fait très très mal
mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
match forcé mais pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de match
mais je suis certain qu'à ce niveau de
la partie karpov doit avoir au moins la
perpétuelle
bien sûr bien sûr ici c'est anatoli
karpov qui joue pour le guide il n'y a
aucun doute là dessus le bon coup dans
cette position je pense que ça lui a
échappé c'est à dire que la anatoli
karpov avait peu de temps donc il a
préféré la sécurité il a monté son roi
sur la casaque 6 et l'idée c'est d'aller
en g7 sécurité on se protège et ensuite
on réfléchit le coup qui
informatiquement était le plus correct
c'était peut-être d'un projet d'un
proche de quel sang froid quand même
d'un proche de avec gros sang-froid
position très compliqué mais peut-être
c'était le bon d'après l'ordinateur le
roi noir trouvera une porte de sortie
les blancs n'ont pas de moyens de gagner
cette position de moyens fort c'est en
tout cas donc ici peut-être d'un proche
de tel beaucoup a noté quoi ici c'est
quand même un coût tout à fait
raisonnable est correct puisque on a
quand même une pièce de plus si on
arrive à stabiliser la situation
et puis qu'est-ce que ça parte c'est
c'est quand même blanchi a montré qu'
ils ont une position de maths sinon
c'est perdu
tout à fait nous qualifier shirov à
trouver des a commencé à trouver des
ressources alors que sa position à l'air
désespéré effectivement dame ces six
échecs roi f7 et la tour d'élite il
continue à mettre ses pièces en jeu à
l'exception autour des 8 ah oui
effectivement la tour ne peut pas être
prise puisque honoré promotion dame en
échec
voilà un échec est la découverte de
possibilités et je pense même que huit
dames avec double échec est pas mal puis
on prend toujours avec l'échec de la
tour est bien aussi bon je pense que
tout va très bien voilà donc ce nom
c'est tourner vite la tour n'est pas en
crise donc en fait alexei shirov d'une
certaine façon à museler les deux
tournois il ya des poissons d'avoir
participé à l'attaqué
tout à fait donc ça c'est l'idée en fait
on voit il ya des paquets pièces qui
sont muselés c'est très très curieux
qu'elle est proche d'eux mais quand même
on est quand même deux pièces diabolique
dame cavaliers s'associent pour mater
quand même effectivement qui est proche
de 3 e 1 et l'a donc anatoli karpov
pourrait sans doute répéter les coups en
janvier3 alexei shirov ne peut pas être
contre la nulle dans cette position il
est nettement moins bien therpauve kg 4
il joue vraiment pour gagner
wen a eu tout à fait ils menacent de
prendre le pion avec matt rapide
ils menacent éventuellement de jouer de
3 aussi dans certaines variantes est
d'ailleurs après dame trembler 6 qui
était la seule défense puisque les
blancs n'ont plus dé chacun dans cette
position peuvent pas faire des achats
courants dont il est blanc peuvent pas
faire ch et perpétuelle est en fait là
les blancs protège tout en grappillant
un petit pion passage de gratton
champions ils ont gratté un pion elana
tels écarts peuvent continuer avec eux
trois il ya un coût qui a dû lui
échapper aux grands anatolie c'est le
coutour h6 alors ça c'était pas à woods
c'est moins évident tourache 6 et 1
seconde
est ce que c'est ce qu'on appelle t-on
sa part dont un sacrifice de déviation
je crois c'est ça on appelle ça comme ça
tout racisme
c'est l'idée ses activités on sait même
pas un sacrifice eu qu'il est protégé
par le cavalier ses protégés par cavani
voilà exactement ce que je pensais en
fait après la prise de la tour éventuel
s'il y'a bon il y avait un dame prend f2
qui pouvait être peut-être destructeur
pour les pour les bolides et c'est bien
c'est un coup de déviation en fait on
essaie de dévier la dame position
compliquée les blancs ont évidemment des
ressources encore anatoli karpov choisi
le coup eux 4 3 puis à l'air très
efficace finalement on a à peu près tous
les thèmes tactique dans cette position
puisque là c'est ainsi qu'on appelle un
sacrifice de d'interposition
d'interposition est effectivement
puisque la pression prend pions le pion
vient s'interposer avec l'action de la
dame blanche
donc il ya damev deux échecs leroy qui
vient en d1 force et là on peut prendre
le pion avec lecavalier et tout arrive
aussi à l'aise puis sam hamad puis c'est
un match où il ya un match assez d'eux
la donne sera obligé de prendre puisque
si le roi vient ici loupe et chaque
keynote le baiser de la mort c'est le
baiser de la main voilà on rappellera
jamais assez la force du couple dame
cavaliers qui est bien supérieur aux
coûts couple dame vous met tout à fait
puisque cavaliers m'ont dit partout
c'est en fait avec dame et cavaliers on
a un échantillonnage complet des pièces
d'échecs
c'est à dire diagonale colonnes et
cavaliers valides
donc c'est plus complet que d'aller fou
qui ne font pas cas van damme b3 échec
au roi roger cette dame ses trois échecs
au roi donc là elle excelle science
menace de faire nul en répétant les
coûts il oblige anatoli karpov à revenir
a changé d'âme c'est à dire à a cassé
son duo dame plus cavalier parce que
sinon c'était et chaque perpétuelle
on en arriverait dans une finale à ce
moment-là peut-être essai de la partie
c'est la partie sur dalle et si ce
chèque s'est faite obligé d'échangés il
n'a pas d'autre choix
enfin les gens qui ont promu troyes il
peut pas éviter les changes des dames on
va dire ne peut pas éviter l'entrée en
finale que anatoli karpov évidemment
prend enfin pâti à contrecoeur mais il
le prend quand même puisqu'il ya
toujours sa pièce de plus tu en prends
et la caisse convoi tampon entoure
toujours impossible pour prendrions
impossible alors toi bon il ya toujours
ce pion de schirrhoffen recettes on peut
pas prendre le vaisseau unique ressource
il est peut-on prendre le peut-on
prendre le pion au fait qui est en notre
avec le cavalier qui semble tout naturel
c'est possible c'est possible ça n'a pas
été jouer je crois non un autre lecteur
peut faire revenir aux 5 alors sur
cavani prend pion aux 3 que se
passait-il position intéressante
vraiment intéressante l'idée temps de
revenir sur le kazakhstan que je suppose
nicolas pour aller gratter hausse est
exactement c'est pas mal c'est vrai que
dans cette position bon les si on enlève
les deux pièces y en échange par exemple
les deux pions de l'ale dames les deux
pions blancs entre les deux pions noirs
c'est nul
senio loïc tour et de cavaliers contre
deux tours c'est nul pas facile pour les
deux tours mais c'est quand même mieux
mais c'est quand même donc le
shirov en fait va maintenant essayer
d'activer ses pions le plus possible
tout en ramenant son roi du côté de
dépit en noir pour essayer de d'échangé
ou de simplifier la position si si c'est
à son avantage
anatoly karpov a joué cavalier ou 5 bon
pourquoi pas il ramène ses pièces près
du roi à noter que le pion de 3 et par
un pion déterminant dans cette position
maintenant le cavalier en hausse un cas
de casse qui sont très fortes fait qu'il
a une case de fourchette au x6 et il a
une case également près du roi qui
permettrait d'attaquer le fameux pions
tout en défendant la tour qui est en
acquittant nashville qui est ça peut
jouer un rôle important puisque
effectivement ça permettra la prise du
psion blanc en recettes alors là on va
accélérer un petit peu puisqu'on arrive
en fin d'émission autour des 5 leroy
montant est 6e 4 ça c'est bon bien joué
de la part de shirov pour tout un tas de
raisons notamment dès que le cavalier
des anatoli karpov bougies à tous avec
cinq échecs
donc ça c'est important et edf 3 échecs
roues avec deux attaques et qui le roi
se rapproche des pions g4 défend roger 3
encore à noter le karpov s'est pas trop
quoi faire de ces tours à noter que ya
une vente qui perd forcé on va quand
même l'un mentionné ces tours pantiero
sept sapeurs de d'une jolie façon tour f
5 échecs
donc là on voit que si le roi vient sur
une de ses deux gas la tour est perdu il
faut donc jouer trois ici tour à 6
échecs aura 17 seule case tour des cinq
échecs et là on voit que le roi n'a que
des mauvaises case oui puisqu'en fait
les rideaux en débattre tout viendra
faire un échec
sur l'un des deux cases et ramassé
l'aderc la torre stand où la force du
pion en 1 4 la force du pied aux 4 qui
soutient la tour des 5 très important
donc après avoir g3 on peut apprendre le
piano 7
que fait-on question pas facile pour
anatolie ils jouent tous rage sept
là il a passé le contrôle le temps il a
bien pu reprendre ses esprits récupérer
un peu la tension nerveuse du de la
crise de temps et ils activent ces
pièces tour f 5 échecs
roger 6 donc la loi 6 échecs
cc c'est quand même encore tendue s'est
encore tendu roger sept tours à 7
et qu'est ce tu fais anatolie alors un
atelier revient à angers 6 shirov
revient à 6 un atelier revient en gelée
cette répétition
scheer reviendra cette répétition de
coûts est ce que j rv à accepter shirov
accepte évidemment pardon risque
anatolie va accepter les noms anatolie
refuse ici ce compromis donc ils se
croient toujours gagnant il se croit
toujours mieux avec des chances de gain
on va dire d'accord alors la partie si
je ne dis pas de bêtises à continuer
comme ça tours h6 puisqu'elle n'était
pas fini à l'heure où on a préparé des
missions tour 17
en fermant le cavalier en rêve 3
c'est-à-dire contrôlant notamment les
caisses des deux là karpov dans cette
position a joué le coup tours 6 et après
tout repos h5
il a pris le pion aux 4 qui défend g4 et
qui cette fois ci assure pratiquement le
gain du 3e set mais pourtant si le
sicile et noir prennent le puits en eaux
cette
après les changes détour le pion
quittant g4 va tomber c'est le problème
c'est tout le problème
objectivement cette position devrait
être nulle c'est incroyable un shirov on
ne sait pas si la sacrifier ou si on l'a
forcé à sacrifier une pièce mieux encore
s'en sortir
peut-être que je suis re va s'en sortir
en tout cas on aura la réponse la
semaine prochaine puisque la partie est
encore en train de se jouer au moment où
on enregistre cette émission c'est à
dire en direct
donc pour l'instant en suspens
voilà donc fin de fin de l'analyse de
partie on va conclure alors mon petit
mot encore sur linares donc nicolas on
rappelle que tu t'occupes de la rubrique
échec à libération donc tu as un avis à
donner sur linares un pronostic qui va
gagner le tournoi est bien difficile
difficile de dire que
kasparov n'est pas le gros gros gros
favoris c'est clair en voyant
cette partie on a envie de dire que
shirov n'est pas très très bien préparé
je fais quand même c'est ça paraît un
peu aberrant de dire ça mais je suis
quand même très surpris que shirov et
puis entrer dans ce type de position
même si on voit tout le contre jeu qu'il
a réussi à obtenir c'est quand même un
joueur d'une classe extraordinaire avait
des ressources impressionnantes
néanmoins la l'ouverture a clairement
été gagné par par les noirs par anatoli
karpov et pourtant shirov savait que
karpov allait lui sortir en quarts aux
canes et donc qu'est-ce qui explique
cette cette déroute 6 précocément dans
la partie à mon avis tout simplement
shirov pensait qu'il avait des bonnes
chances à noter que la partie est quand
même extrêmement compliqué ça a été
simplifiée dans la mesure où on ne
comprend pas forcément tout c'est du
très très haut niveau c'est un vrai
débat un vrai débat très complexe
anatoly karpov qu'il fait pas de
faiblesse et alexei shirov qui lui joue
tous pour un fou c'est mon royaume pour
le foot cases blanches partie donc
extrêmement compliquée avec des choses
qu'on n'a pas forcément comprise des
choses qui n'ont pas forcément été jouée
au mieux à mon avis la partie et
hypertendu tout ça donc je vois
effectivement kasparov prendre le
le leadership rapidement sur ce tournoi
j'ai envie de dire que karpov va
peut-être faire la surprise à ces
retards peuvent c'est un peu ta
génération
merci bien en tout cas jusque là plus
que l'europe racines et c'est dans ce
sens là qu'est ce que je faisais ça 30
c'est peut-être un peu côté sentimental
j'aimerais bien voir un bon karpov un
grand karpov sur sur ce tournoi
on attend beaucoup de gris tchouk je
pense qu'il aura il va souffrir comme je
le dit sur ce sur ce sursaut linares je
verrai bien peut-être car peuvent
prendre la seconde place et en 3e shirov
troisième shirov et peut-être les coups
quand même solide je vois le je vois les
coachs et rohff sur un même plan sur ce
minerai c'est très bon s'est
effectivement très très ambitieux et
très risquées comme pronostics mais bon
je me plais à dire que j'aimerais voir
carpeaux france et qu'on placera bien
alors une petite news pour finir tournoi
cappelle-la-grande traditionnel le plus
grand open de france un des plus forts
du monde plus de 100 grands maîtres
chaque année 650 joueurs 300 classes et
internationaux venus de en général plus
de 100 nations différentes c'est très
impressionnant
le tournoi commence demain fini dimanche
de la semaine suivante on aura un
compte-rendu spéciale de marque santoro
mans qui va aller jouer le tournoi là
bas parmi les français jean-marc
degraeve laurent frayssinet igor nataf
arnaud hauchard manuela peas et là ça
sera un haut représentant rigueur nataf
qui est hyper concentré il est prêt sur
les starting blocks pour qu'on leur
souhaite donc bonne chance à tous ce
tournoi très dur pour avis lors de la
gold in hagenstein vivront nicolas merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
édition merci et loi est donc bien au
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau
évidemment spécial linares avec parties
commentées et tout le tralala
et